Tom Brady is officially taking the
broadcast booth in 2024 which means he's
officially replacing the fan favorite
Greg Olsen it's a weird situation on one
hand it's Tom Brady and when he says he
believes he can quote provide a pretty
unique experience he's not wrong he's
the most decorated QB of all time and he
has Decades of experience in the
football world but then there's Greg
Olsen who also excelled on the field and
who really stepped into his role this
season and did a hell of a job in the
broadcast Booth Tom said he loves Greg
and spoke about how incredible of a job
Greg has done he said he will be
incredibly successful at anything he
puts his mind to the chances of Brady
being bad at this are very low he's not
coming in without practice it's Tom
Brady he's going to be doing the most he
said he's been studying and doing a ton
of research and although he said he's
been doing and will continue doing dry
runs and practice he said fortunately he
had 23 years of sitting in meeting rooms
and being in game plan meetings so that
will most definitely help